the eyes to the right 340
the nose to the left 263
so the eyes have it the eyes have it
the first parliamentary hurdle cleared
the government insists the bill is
necessary for brexit
despite it breaking international law
but it didn't look like the prime
minister
much enjoyed hearing the views to the
contrary either he wasn't straight with
the country
about the deal in the first place or he
didn't understand it with a majority of
80 any real problems will come not from
the opposition
but from the conservative benches the
rebellion was limited this time
but there were indications the later
stages of this bill
could become more difficult for the
government i've voted in ways
in this house that i have regretted in
the past
but i don't believe i've ever gone into
a lobby to vote
in a way that i knew was wrong and i
won't be doing it on this occasion
either
i do hope that the prime minister
reflects on what is going on and listens
to the concerns of this house
and comes back with a solution that
allows me
to skip through the division lobby
during his speech the prime minister did
attempt to address some of those
concerns
if they were ever needed ministers would
return to this house
with a statutory instrument which a vote
would be held the former attorney
general who yesterday admonished
the prime minister for considering
breaking international law
welcomed that move saying in a tweet i
hope that further developments to make
clear the government's intention to act
lawfully
and consistently with our treaty
obligations will enable my support in
the coming days
but that has worried some hard-line
brexiteers who say the prime minister
should hold firm
the prime minister's got a massive
majority tonight he's got the backing of
the house of commons
he needs to press on this bill and he
does not need to be amended
and should not be amended with mps now
set to get into the detail
the legislation the prime minister's
majority and perhaps his wider
negotiating strategy with the eu
are all about to be put to the test tom
rayner sky news westminster